[Music]
from sitcom Titans to Oscar nominees and
the character actors in between these
are the people behind or in the family
who have sadly passed away since their
time visiting the bunker household
before playing Archie Bunker Carol Okana
started his acting career on the stage
in Dublin Island and his native New York
City after making his TV debut on Sunday
showcase he went on to appear on the
likes of Gunsmoke Bonanza and the outer
limits among others butto Conor's most
successful role was of course Arie whom
he played on both All in the Family and
the spin-off Archie Bunker's Place after
his time as the bunker patriarch came to
an end OK Conor went on to star in the
TV version of In the Heat of the Night
he also became one of a select few to
win Prime Time Emmys in both the comedy
and drama categories offscreen OK Conor
and his wife Nancy Fields had an adopted
son named Hugh who died by suicide in
1995 after a long struggle with
addiction that inspired his father to do
a number of public service announcements
in the '90s for partnership for a
drug-free America get between your kids
and drugs any way you can OK Conor died
in 2001 at the age of 76 from a heart
attack and complications of
diabetes as Edith Bunker Jean sableton
was kind and understanding though she
also had to enjoy the constant ridicule
of her husband nevertheless Edith was
the heart of All in the Family and there
were times she would prove Archie wrong
and help him find his empathy like Carol
OK Conor Stapleton was born in New York
City and also started out on the stage
as the daughter of an opera singer the
Performing Arts were in her blood she
eventually made it to Broadway as part
of famous musicals like funny girl and
Dam Yankees stapleton's pre All in the
Family TV credits includes the likes of
the Patty Juke show my three sons and
Dennis the Menace she only appeared on
five episodes of the spin-off Archie bun
place and the decision was then made to
have Edith die from a stroke it wasn't
supposed to be like this you know
Stapleton herself died in 2013 at the
age of 90 after a long and extensive
career Sherman Hemley played George
Jefferson who proved to be popular
enough to become the lead on his own
spin-off show The Jeffersons on All in
the Family George's Archie Bunker's
neighbor who he often buted heads with
as the Jefferson theme song made famous
George and his family moved on over from
their former neighborhood in Queens to a
deluxe apartment in the sky in Manhattan
The Jeffersons ran for a whopping 11
Seasons from
1975 through 1985 Hemsley also enjoyed
an extensive stage career and appeared
on other TV shows like dinosaurs and The
Fresh Prince of ballet when Hemsley died
in 2012 at the age of 74 from lung
cancer his will left everything to a
woman named Flora his dear friend and
business partner Hemley wasn't buried
for over a month after his death because
a Philadelphia man named Richard thoron
claimed to be his long lost brother the
drawn out legal proceedings were
eventually resolved when the Court ruled
in Flora's favor Isabelle sford played
George Jefferson's wife Louise who was
lovingly known as Wheezy whereas Archie
and George were hot-headed and
frequently sparring Edith and Lise were
always trying to figure out how to calm
their husbands down Isabelle is
portrayed as kind and sensible like
Edith though much sharper Stanford was
born in New York City and joined
Harlem's American Negro theater and the
star players after graduating from high
school she made her stage debut in 1946
as she appeared in both Broadway and off
Bradway Productions in 1960 after
separating from her husband she and her
three children moved to Los Angeles
where her movie and TV career really
kicked off after appearing in the 1967
film Guess who's coming to dinner she
caught the attention of Norman Leah who
then cast on All in the Family I got
something to say to you boy just exactly
what you're trying to pull here during
her time on the Jefferson sford earned
five Golden Globe and seven Emmy
nominations when she won an Emmy in 1981
for outstanding lead actress in a comedy
series she became the first black
actress to Triumph in that category she
died in 2004 in Los Angeles at the age
of
86 George and Louise Jefferson's son
lonol initially appeared on the first
episode of all in the family's first
season meet the bunkers Lionel is
notable for being a positive depiction
of an opinionated black man which was
rather revolutionary for the time lonor
doesn't let AR's casual racism bother
him as he instead laughs it off as a
sign of his neighbor backwards thinking
he sees Archie as more ignorance than
evil and often patronizes him still
Archie considers Lionel a friend and
even something of a menty what a French
for L liono was played by Mike Evans on
both in the family and the Jefferson
during the first few seasons of the
latter he marries his biracial wife
Jenny and they have a daughter named
Jessica Evans eventually left the
Jeffersons to work on the sitcom Good
Times which he helped create he was
placed on the Jeffersons by Damon Evans
who was not related to Mike despite
their shared last name Mike Evans
returned for the final season of The
Jeffersons and died of throat cancer at
the age of 57 in
2006 Alan Melvin played Archie's
neighbor and best friend Barney Hefner
before he played Barney though he showed
up in the season 2 episode Archie in the
lockup as a desk officer at a police
precinct Melvin's popularity rose during
his time as Barney and he ended up
becoming a series regular on all four
seasons of the spin-off Archie Bunker
Place born in Kansas City Missouri
Melvin had a sort of expressive face at
TV was invented for he appeared on such
classic sitcoms as go mile the Dick Van
djk show The Andy Griffith Show and my
favorite martian he also famously played
Sam the butcher Alice's boyfriend on The
Brady Bunch Melvin died in 2008 from
cancer at the age of 84 and he justo
happens to be buried near Carol okona
Betty Garrett and Vincent gardinia
played the Bunker's liberal Catholic
neighbors Irene and Frank Lorenzo Irene
is Irish while Frank is Italian thus
highlighting the Multicultural makeup of
their Queen's neighborhood Irene is also
something of a feminist for the day
she's handy with tools and she often
fixes things around her own house as
well as the bunkers Archie even gets her
job as a forklift operator at the same
plant where he works I got the
job another Missouri native Garrett
appears on Broadway in the 1940s and had
a contract with MGM during Hollywood
studio era her most notable TV role
other than Irene was the land lady Edna
on L and Shirley Garrett w a Golden
Globe her portrayal of Irene though the
character was phased out of the show in
latest Seasons Garrett's TV career
continued on such shows as The Golden
Girls and Murder She Wrote she continued
acting into the early 2000s on the likes
of Gray's Anatomy and Boston Public she
died in 2011 at the age of 91 of an atic
aneurism Vincent gardenia played Frank
Lorenzo as a boisterous fellow who loves
to sing and cook he once worked as a
Salesman though what he sold is never
actually mentioned before he was Frank
gardenia appeared on an earlier episode
of All in the Family as a man who sells
his house to The Jeffersons and he also
played as swinger in a season 3 episode
gardenia was born in Naples Italy in
1920 during the course of his long and
varied acting career he was nominated
for two Academy Awards for 1973's Bang
the Drum Slowly and 1987's Moonstruck
when gardenia died in 1992 at the age of
7 2 it led to quite the theatrical
conundrum he was in Philadelphia to
perform on stage in the comedy breaking
legs he originated the Roll Off Broadway
the year before on the morning of the
final preview show it was discovered
that he died of a heart attack in his
hotel room the show went on though with
the opening performance dedicated to his
memory George Jefferson's brother Henry
was played by Mel Stewart an actor
director and musician he was introduced
along with Louise and lonol before
Sherman Hemley join the cast as George
Henry and George only appear in one
episode together on All in the Family
which focuses on Henry's going away
party for his move to Chicago the move
was a way of phasing out the character
who never appeared on The Jeffersons I
want to thank you buer for letting me
know and letting me see that uh some
white folks are better than other white
folks though Henry was only a bit player
on All in the Family Stuart enjoyed an
extensive TV career his next project
After All in the Family was roll out a
shortlived series about black soldiers
during World War II he also appeared on
such shows as good times the loveboat
and The Golden Girls his last onscreen
role was the 1993 movie made in America
he died in 2002 from outsider's disease
at the age of
72 be Arthur played Edith's feminist
cousin mud who went on to have her own
aonomus spin-off more than Archie often
buted heads and unlike Lionel Jefferson
who let Archie's IGN an slip with a quip
M was famous for fighting back you're
fat M appeared on one episode of All in
the Family in season 1 and then one more
episode in season 2 which served as a
backdoor pilot for her own show born in
1922 in Brooklyn Arthur started her
career on the stage she won a Tony in
1966 for best featured actress in a
musical for MIM after M she landed
another iconic role as Dorothy on The
Golden Girls she continued acting until
the the 2000s appearing on such shows as
Malcolm in the Middle and Kirby
enthusiasm she even returned to Broadway
for a 2002 production called be Arthur
on Broadway just between friends she
died in 2009 from lung cancer at the age
of
86 Bob Hastings played Archie's friend
Tommy Kelce the owner of the bar that
the bunker patriarch frequent that's the
place where Archy can go to relax and
have a drink it's basically his home
away from home so much so that when
Tommy puts it for sale Archie mortgages
his own house to buy it this catalyzes
the transition from All in the Family to
the spin-off Archie Bunker's Place the
Brooklyn Born Hastings started his
career on the radio where he played
Archie Andrews in a 1945 show based on
Archie Comics he transitioned to TV soon
after and showed up on the likes of
Hogan's Heroes Green Acres and male's
Navy from 1978 to 1986 he played Captain
Ramsey on the daytime soap opera General
Hospital in the '90s he turned to voice
acting which included the part of
Commissioner Gordon on Batman the
Animated Series among other roles in the
DC Animated Universe Hastings died in
2014 from prostate cancer at the age of
89 though he never actually acted on All
in the Family Creator and executive
producer Norman Leah was obviously
indispensable to the show you could even
go a step further and say that he was
essential to an entire era of TV in
addition to All in the Family he helped
dream up The Jeffersons and mod and he
executive produced One Day at a Time
Samford and Son good times and Mary
Harman at one point he was responsible
for three of the four top rated TV shows
in the country Leah CAU his big break
back in the 1950s Penning jokes for Dean
Martin and Jerry Lewis younger viewers
might be more familiar with the times
that he collaborated with All in the
Family Star Rob rer who's gone on to
have a steady directing career Leah had
a hand in r classic films This Is Spinal
Tap standby me and The Princess Bride
the Oscar nominated multi awardwinning
Leah passed away on December 5th 2023 at
the age of